Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, das off the air Radio. Ausgabe Nummer sieben, am Mikrofon, wie gewohnt, Tim Pritlav. Heute wieder mit einem interessanten Gespräch, aber auch natürlich mit interessanter Musik. Wieder ein Mix aus dem unstillbaren Vorrat der Creative Commons Bibliothek. Wir hören den ID-Mix 001 von Elliptic Digital Drive. Ja, ich bin nicht alleine, sondern mit mir ist Markus Beckedahl. Hallo Markus. Ja, Markus ist auch CCC-Mitglied, aber vor allem bekannt durch sein Engagement über die Webseite netzpolitik.org, ein Weblog, was recht eifrig informiert über zahlreiche Vorgänge. Gibt ja eine Menge zu berichten. Wo würdest du selber so die Schwerpunkte von netzpolitik.org so sehen?
Ganz klar in Richtung Freisoftware, Open Source Technologien, Freiswissen, Bürgerrechte im Internet, ja.
Das hört schon mal eine ganze Menge. Auf jeden Fall. Du bist ja auch auf dem kommenden Chaos Communication Congress als Speaker vertreten. Wenn ich das so richtig sehe, bist du für drei oder nein, sogar schon für vier Vorträge eingetragen. Kann man mal kurz erwähnen. Der eine ist European Politics Concerning Digital Rights. Worum wird es dabei gehen?
Da geht es darum, dass auf europäischer Ebene verschiedenste Richtlinien in Arbeit sind, beziehungsweise schon fertiggestellt worden sind, die Bürgerrechte im digitalen Raum oder Freiheiten im digitalen Raum extrem gefährden. Darüber wollen wir aufklären, wir wollen einen Überblick geben, dass es mehr gibt als nur Vorratsdatenspeicherungen und Softwarepatente, wo man darauf achten müsste.
Der zweite Vortrag dreht sich dann auch konkret um Blogs, also auch um die Erfahrungen, denke ich mal, die du gesammelt hast. Wie lange läuft netzpolitik.org jetzt bereits?
In dieser Version seit eineinhalb Jahren. Vorläufer habe ich vor drei Jahren gestartet.
Also in dieser Version, also unter der Domain netzpolitik.org?
Unter der Domain netzpolitik.org habe ich schon vor drei Jahren über den WSIS berichtet, aber jetzt so in dieser Form umfassend seit August letzten Jahres.
Okay, da ist das Stichwort jetzt auch schon gefallen. WSIS ist dann das Thema vom dritten Vortrag, ein Review. Da gehen wir jetzt auch gleich noch mal stärker darauf ein und vielleicht dann noch mal, und dann bist du noch mit dabei, wenn es darum geht Sony die Levitin zu lesen mit ihren Rootkit.
Ja, die gescheiterte Einführungskampagne des Sony Rootkits.
Ja, das Stichwort ist bereits gefallen. WSIS steht für World Summit on the Information Society. Tolles Wort. Was bedeutet das? Es ist eine internationale Konferenz ausgerichtet von der ITU, von der International Telecommunications Union, also der Verband aus allen alten Postunternehmen.
Das ist eine UN-Organisation.
Mittlerweile.
Schon seit über 50 oder 100 Jahren. Also um 50 Jahre gibt es die UNO. Ich glaube, die ITU gibt es schon ein bisschen länger.
Ja, genau. Aber es war im Prinzip schon immer die versammelten Post- und Telekommunikationsunternehmen. Also Unternehmen waren es ja damals noch nicht, aber das, was bei uns irgendwie Deutsche Post war. Und gut, das wurde dann der UN unterstellt. Und worum ging es jetzt bei diesem World Summit on the Information Society? Das war ja nicht der erste.
Ja, das ist ein UN-Weltgipfel, diesmal zur Informationsgesellschaft. UN-Weltgipfel kennt man normalerweise von Kyoto, von Johannesburg und anderen, die sich halt um dringende Fragestellungen der Menschheit beschäftigten. Und im Jahr 2000 haben die Vereinten Nationen ihre Millenniums Declaration vorgestellt. Das sind so für die nächsten 50 Jahre die Probleme, die man anpacken möchte auf internationaler Ebene. Hunger, Wasser, Informationsgesellschaft. Und da im Jahr 2000 die New Economy gerade so ihren Höhepunkt erreichte, hat man gedacht, okay, das Problem Informationsgesellschaft und die digitale Spaltung weltweit sollte man als erstes angehen. Und hat erstmalig einen zweigeteilten Gipfelprozess gestartet. Das heißt zweigeteilt, es gab zwei Gipfel. Den ersten im Dezember 2003 in Genf und jetzt den zweiten vor einem Monat in Tunis. Und Ziel war einerseits eine globale Vision an der Informationsgesellschaft zu entwickeln und zweitens Lösungen zu finden, wie man die digitale Spaltung weltweit zurückdrängen kann.
Wer nimmt jetzt an so einem Summit teil? Also was waren denn jetzt eigentlich die, also woraus haben sich die Teilnehmer zusammengesetzt?
Ja, das Besondere an diesem Gipfel war, dass erstmalig ein sogenannter Multi-Stakeholder-Gipfel geplant und durchgeführt wurde. Multi-Stakeholder bedeutet, es gibt verschiedene Stakeholder. Bisher auf UN-Ebene gab es eigentlich immer nur die Regierung als den einen Stakeholder. Jetzt beim Thema Informationsgesellschaft dachte man sich, man kann eigentlich nichts ohne die Industrie weltweit beschließen. Die Industrie als einen Stakeholder, die eigentlich das Internet besitzt, die die Leitungen besitzt. Ja, und wenn man schon die Industrie an Bord holt, dann muss man natürlich auch die Menschen berücksichtigen. Die sogenannte Zivilgesellschaft. Unter den Begriff Zivilgesellschaft fällt eigentlich alles auf UN-Ebene, was nicht Regierungen sind und was nicht Industrie ist. Also klassische NGOs, Wissenschaftler, Einzelpersonen, eigentlich der ganze Rest.
Und du warst dann sozusagen auch als NGO unterwegs?
Ja, ich war als Mitglied der Zivilgesellschaft in diesem Gipfelprozess involviert.
Ihr habt also einen Koordinierungskreis gegründet, den WSIS-Koordinierungskreis schon vor einigen Jahren.
Ja, da haben wir eigentlich alle Akteure in Deutschland, die sich mit dem WSIS-Prozess beschäftigen, auf zivilgesellschaftlicher Seite miteinander vernetzt und auch geschlossen gegenüber der Bundesregierung, beispielsweise als Stakeholder, sind wieder aufgetreten. Und gleichzeitig waren wir auf internationaler Ebene natürlich auch wiederum innerhalb der Koalition, der NGOs, der Internationalen Zivilgesellschaft vernetzt.
Wird sowas dann eigentlich dann von der Bundesrepublik noch in irgendeiner Form gefördert? Also, welche Mittel habt ihr da jetzt aufbringen müssen, um daran teilzunehmen?
Ja, Förderung gibt es da nichts, da sind andere Länder wie Kanada oder Dänemark viel weiter. Wir hatten sozusagen die Ehre oder ich hatte die Ehre von der Bundesregierung als Mitglied der Regierungsdelegation wenigstens so ein blaues Badge zu bekommen, wo halt Regierungsdelegation drauf stand, aber Fahrtkosten mussten wir selbst bezahlen. Da haben wir glücklicherweise die Heinrich-Bölt-Stiftung gefunden, die halt für die Mitglieder der Regierungsdelegation aus zivilgesellschaftlicher Sicht, da waren wir fünf, die Fahrtkosten und die Hotelunterbringung finanzierte. Andererseits wäre es uns nicht möglich gewesen, nach Tunis zu fliegen.
Okay, das war schon mal ganz hilfreich, wenn auch die Regierung sich dort etwas mehr anstrengen könnte.
Auf jeden Fall.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, also die Regierungen sind vertreten, die Firmen sind vertreten, die NGOs sind vertreten. In was für Kräfte und Interessen übersetzt sich denn das? Also wie muss man sich das vorstellen auf diesem Gipfel? Wer redet da eigentlich mit wem und wer fällt, werden da eigentlich Beschlüsse auf diesem Gipfel selber gefällt, die werden auch eigentlich im Wesentlichen schon im Vorfeld ausgekungelt, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also, jedem dieser beiden Gipfel ging jeweils eine zweijährige Vorbereitungszeit voraus. Während dieser Vorbereitungszeit gab es verschiedene Prep-Coms, sogenannte Vorbereitungskonferenzen, die immer zwei Wochen lang gingen. Es gab vor jedem Gipfel vier verschiedene dieser Prep-Coms. Und da treffen sich halt alle Stakeholder und man redet halt miteinander, also die ganze Zeit zwei Wochen durchgängig Arbeitsgruppen zu einzelnen Themen oder Clannery-Sitzungen, wo dann halt hauptsächlich Regierungen miteinander reden. Und wenn man Glück hat als Zivilgesellschaft, darf man wenigstens auch mal dran teilnehmen oder vielleicht morgens mal.
Hast du da auch dran teilgenommen?
Ja, ich habe den meisten teilgenommen, die in Genf stattfanden. Genf war halt relativ nahe, konnte man erreichen, konnte man mit Schlafsack und Isomatte auch hinreisen.
Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen die Homebase von der ITU, oder?
Ja genau, wir haben auch größtenteils in der ITU getagt.
Ja, die Player. Ja, welche Kräfte und Interessen sind dort vertreten? Das haben wir versucht jetzt hier schon mal anzusprechen. Also wen siehst du denn da im Wesentlichen am Wirken?
Erstmal muss man unterscheiden, es gibt verschiedene Blöcke auf internationaler Ebene der Staaten. Da haben wir ganz klar die westlichen Staaten, Europa oder Europäische Union, USA, Kanada, Australien, die halt einen Blocker geben. Dann gibt es die Staaten der G20, das sind halt die aufstrebenden Stellenländer wie Brasilien, Indien, China und so weiter. Und dann gibt es halt den großen Block der Entwicklungsländer.
Also Afrika und damit natürlich auch Tunisien als Gastgeber quasi selber.
Ja, Tunisien auch, ja.
Und im Bereich der Firmen, also treten die denn auch geschlossen auf?
Die treten hauptsächlich in Form ihrer Interessenverbände auf internationaler Ebene auf. Business Software Alliance oder International Chamber of Commerce, aber auch große multinationale Unternehmen wie Microsoft sind natürlich auch da mit ihren Lobbyisten vertreten. Bei Microsoft war es ganz interessant, die waren in der ersten Gipfelphase eigentlich kaum vertreten. Da konnten in die Gipfelpapiere noch Bekenntnisse zu freier Software durchgebracht werden. Jetzt im zweiten Gipfelteil war halt die US-Delegation voll mit Microsoft-Lobbyisten und die haben halt alles in diese Richtung gut abgedeckt bzw. abgeblockt und verhindert, dass zu große Bekenntnisse zu freier Software und Linux und so weiter.
Sind denn da noch Bekenntnisse übrig geblieben?
Ja, irgendwo unter Ferner liefen. Also Gipfelpapiere jetzt, die waren auch nicht besonders spannend.
Okay, naja, gut, das lenkt natürlich jetzt auch gleich über zu, was denn eigentlich dabei rausgekommen ist. Also welche Art von Beschlüsse sind dort tatsächlich gefällt worden, also teilweise im Vorfeld. Was ist davon noch vor Ort abgesegnet worden?
Also wir müssen auch hier wieder die beiden Gipfel voneinander trennen. 2003 in Genf ist ein allgemeines Visionspapier, wie es die Regierung nannten, verabschiedet worden. Und da stand mit looming Worten eigentlich geschrieben drin, dass man Internet eigentlich jetzt ins letzte Dorf in Afrika bringen möchte, dass die Informationsgesellschaft für alle da sein soll. Und im Endeffekt war es ein Minimalkonsens, worauf sich die ganzen Staaten dieser Erde geeinigt haben. Und wir sprachen halt davon damals, dass es halt alles andere als eine Vision ist. Und dann mal schön, dass man sich über unterhalten hat. Und zwei Fragen waren halt vollkommen ungeklärt beim ersten Gipfel. Die eine Frage war, auf einmal poppte das Thema Internet Governance hoch. Also wer kontrolliert das Domain Name System, was im Moment von ICANN kontrolliert wird? Die ICANN wird wiederum vom US-Handelsministerium kontrolliert. Also im Endeffekt haben die USA die Kontrolle über das Internet. Viele Staaten wollten da eigentlich nicht mehr mitspielen, sondern stellten sich halt so eine echte Weltregierung vor. So am besten unter der Ägide der ITU, die auch gerade irgendwie ein bisschen arbeitslos wurde, so durch Internet und so weiter. Ja, und die Frage des Internet Governance war ungelöst oder einfach heruntergebrochen wie alle Medienestaten, ITU, der ICON. Die zweite Frage war gelöst, ja, wie finanziert man jetzt die Verlängerung der digitalen Spaltung, wenn man jetzt irgendwie innerhalb von zehn Jahren überall Internet hinlegen will? Das kostet ja Geld. Da standen sich eigentlich auch so zwei Positionen konträr gegenüber. Das eine war, dass die westlichen Staaten unbedingt wollten, dass arme afrikanische Länder ihre Marktbarrieren verringern sollten. So in Deutschland stellt er sich vor, na ja, wenn die das machen, dann kommt da vielleicht jemand hin und baut die ganzen Kabel und Masten auf. Aber die wollen natürlich auch ihr Geschäft machen. Auf der anderen Seite waren halt Vorschläge wie zum Beispiel ein Digital Solidarity Fonds, also ein weltweiter Fonds, womit man halt Entwicklungshilfeprojekte im IT-Bereich unterstützt. Und da beide Fragen ungeklärt waren, hat man halt sich entschlossen, gut, dann richten wir halt eine Arbeitsgruppe ein und hat zwei Working Groups on Internet Governance und Financing-Mechanism unter der Idee der Kontrolle von Co-Fiat Anan auf UN-Ebene aufgedockt und hat halt eineinhalb Jahre beide Arbeitsgruppen werkeln lassen. Und die Ergebnisse dieser Arbeitsgruppen sollten halt in das zweite Gipfel-Dokument jetzt einfließen, in das Tunis-Dokument. Und da ging es drum eine kleine Evaluation, was man vor zwei Jahren beschlossen hat, eine Lösung der Frage des Internet Governance und Finanzierungsmechanismen. Und bei beiden hat man eigentlich auch wirklich keine Lösung gefunden. Also das war das Enttäuschende dieses Gipfels. Andererseits auch wiederum vielleicht auch ganz gut so, dass Fragen nicht letztendlich geklärt werden konnten, weil die Frage des Internet Governance auf der einen Seite Kontrolle der USA, auf der anderen Seite Kontrolle, wenn noch China dabei ist, ist beides nicht wirklich schön als Lösung.
Die Governance, da ist ja auch alles sehr buzzwordgeladen, was man so von so einer Konferenz mitbringt, wenn ich das so höre. Vielleicht nochmal kurz ein bisschen zurückspulen, auch mal ein bisschen Verständnis für diese komplexe Materie zu erzeugen. Denn du hast ja auch gerade wieder gesagt, dass ja so ein sehr gängiger Begriff, der immer wieder herumfliegt, die Internetregierung und das wird ja dann auch nicht selten dieser ICAN zugeschrieben. Dazu muss man sagen, ICAN, ICAN, steht offiziell zunächst einmal nur für Internet, was war nochmal das C? For Assigned Names and Numbers. Also im Prinzip ist die Organisation ursprünglich mal mehr oder weniger ausschließlich dafür vorgesehen worden, um so was wie Domains und IP-Adressenzuteilungen zu walten, hat aber, ich weiß gar nicht, wodurch, eine extreme Bedeutung bekommen, zumindest in der Diskussion. Das ist jetzt auch eine persönliche Wahrnehmung und ist auch eine Wahrnehmung, die ich so im Web immer wieder finde. ICAN ist sehr unter Beobachtung, es gibt da viele Diskussionen in Blogs, gibt sogar ein eigenes ICAN-Blog, mehrere, sogar ein Podcast und ja mehrere natürlich. Klar, also das ist auch ganz gut und bewachengut da unter Beteiligung. ICAN selber ist durch einige Veränderungen durchgegangen. Ganz am Anfang gab es ja da auch diese Beteiligung der Netzbürger. Ich glaube, das haben sie am Anfang mal so reingeschrieben und sich nicht wirklich darüber Gedanken gemacht, was damit eigentlich ausgelöst wird. Das hat unter anderem dazu geführt, dass mal Wahlen abgehalten wurden im Internet, die ja dann hier für den europäischen Raum von Anni, hier auch aus dem Club gewonnen wurden, der dann zwei Jahre lang in der ICANN mitgewaltet hat. Und jetzt ist so die Bedeutung der ICANN ein bisschen unklar, habe ich so den Eindruck. Welche Rolle hat denn die ICANN konkret auf der WSIS gespielt? Also waren die als Gruppe dort auch vertreten? Haben die da eine moderierende, leitende Funktion gehabt in irgendeiner Form?
Die waren, wenn als Observer vertreten, als Observer so wie Zivilgesellschaft, dass ICANN-Vertreter da ja auch anwesend waren, aber sie hatten da keine große Rolle.
Dann vielleicht jetzt nochmal zurück zu diesem Governance-Ding. Also wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich die Internet-Regierung?
Ja, schwierige Frage. Also ICANN verwaltet das DNS-System, damit eigentlich das Herzstück des Internets. Gleichzeitig debattiert ICANN die Einführung von neuen Top-Level-Domains. Sehr viel Zeit nimmt im Moment die Diskussion um die XXX-Domain, XXX-Domain.
Porno-Ja-Nein, genau.
Genau, wo Staaten wie der Vatikan massiv irgendwie Lobbigen betreiben. Das einzige Mal, dass ich mitbekommen habe, dass der Vatikan im Bereich Informationsgesellschaft sich international einsetzt.
Und sind die dafür oder sind die dagegen?
Die finden das nicht so toll.
Echt? Aber können doch eigentlich ganz froh sein, wenn der ganze Schmutz dann in definierte Top-Level-Domain geschoben wird.
Das ist eigentlich auch keine spannende Frage, aber die beschäftigen sich da jahrelang halt mit der Einführung von solchen Domains.
Aber sie reden sich den Mundfusselig. Das ist wirklich unfassbar. Ich verstehe auch gar nicht, warum es ist. Ja, dabei gibt es so viele lustige Top-Level-Domains, die schon längst hätten mal da sein sollen.
Aber das ist halt so eine spannende Frage immer, wer hat das Recht eigentlich, neue Top-Level-Domains zu verwalten? Ja, welche brauchen wir? Überlasset das ganze System das? Und ja, viele spannende Fragen oder nicht so spannende Fragen. Ja, das Modell der ICANN ist eigentlich schon ein bisschen in Richtung Multistakeholder-Gen, das heißt, man bindet schon Vertreter der Wirtschaft und der Zivilgesellschaft ein. Allerdings, ja, alle Entscheidungen, die ICANN fällt, die laufen letztendlich übers US-Handelsministerium. Und wir haben noch eine weitere Diskrepanz. Ah, es gibt so die ICANN-Mitarbeiter, also die ICANN-Bürokratie, die halt zu sich eigentlich den ganzen Tag damit beschäftigt und ihr Geld dadurch verdient, ICANN zu managen. Und es gibt halt die größtenteils, ja, freiwilligen Bordmitglieder oder Advisory Committee-Mitglieder, die halt in ihrer Freizeit oder Arbeitszeit nebenbei mal zu ICANN-Treffen fahren und da was mitbeschließen.
So, jetzt muss sich Glatt ja noch mal willkommen heißen, hier in dieser Sendung, weil ich habe nämlich jetzt gerade den Regler gefunden, mit dem ich deinen komischen Hall-Effekt ausgleichen kann. Das ist nämlich gerade zweimal aufgenommen worden, wie ich das gerade festgestellt habe. Das klingt doch schon sehr viel angenehmer. Noch mal ein kleiner Test.
Ja, hallo.
Ah, toll. Super. Okay. Wunderwelt der Audio-Technologie, ich habe es schon mal gesagt. Podcasting ist auch ein Forschungsobjekt, zumindest hier bei uns. Jetzt muss ich erst mal wieder in die Spur kommen. ICANN, genau. Wohl diskutiertes Feld war natürlich auch die Rolle der USA. Das bezieht sich besonders auf die ICANN, denn zunächst einmal ist die ICANN als konkrete reale Organisation derzeit ja immer noch eine Organisation nach kalifornischem Recht und untersteht mehr oder weniger dem amerikanischen Handelsministerium. Da kann man natürlich lange darüber diskutieren, inwieweit da tatsächlich jetzt ein realer Bezug wirklich vorhanden ist und ob das wirklich für die tägliche Arbeit der ICANN relevant ist. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall Bedenken. Und der Druck, gerade aus Europa, ist auch in den letzten Jahren stark angestiegen, weil man sich eben einfach die Sache nicht so aus der Hand nehmen lässt.
Ja, eigentlich nicht so aus Europa, sondern eher von Staaten wie China, Pakistan, Brasilien, die halt ja A, ihre nationale Souveränität in Gefahr sehen, wenn halt praktisch oder theoretisch das Internet aus den USA einfach mal in ihrem Land ausgeschaltet werden kann. Ich glaube, es gab so Fälle, als Afghanistan unter Beschuss stand, dass halt Afghanistan mal weg war aus dem Netz.
Ja, ich glaube, die Punkt-AF lag dann auch mal bei irgendeiner amerikanischen Firma rum. Und zwar meines Wissens auch schon im Irak war dasselbe Problem. Im Irak, genau, hatten wir das auch bei Serbien in dem Krieg. Weiß ich es jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau, da ist auch irgendwas gelaufen. Aber ich glaube, da haben auch die Serben auch ähnliche Spiele mit Toplampe Domains gespielt. Also man merkt auf jeden Fall, das ist auch ein Ort, an dem Macht ausgeübt werden kann und auch Macht ausgeübt wird. Und das ist sicherlich bedenklich. Und von daher gab es immer große Kritik an dieser Konstellation. Die USA, das ist so mein Eindruck aus der Berichterstattung, wie ich sie wahrgenommen habe, geht einfach nur so weit die Schritte mit, wie sie sich wirklich genötigt sieht. Weil das einzige wirkliche Druckmittel, was es gibt, meiner Auffassung nach, ist der Split. Also wenn man sich die Technik des Internets anschaut, wäre es ja heute schon problemlos möglich, mehrere separate Internets zu haben. Und zwar allein dadurch, dass man eben das DNS-System aufspaltet. In dem Moment, wo wir nicht mehr dieselben Root-Server benutzen, wie alle anderen, hätten wir im Prinzip unseren komplett eigenen Blick. Man würde immer noch denselben IP-Adressraum benutzen natürlich. Auch das könnte man natürlich abspalten, aber das wäre wahrscheinlich eher unmöglich. Aber das DNS-System ist auf jeden Fall so eine Sache, wo was passieren könnte. Dass das konkret passiert, halte ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt für realistisch. Aber es ist natürlich auch etwas, worüber die USA mal wieder nachdenken muss, weil sie kriegen derzeit sowieso eine ganze Menge Druck an allen Fronten. Das merkt man ja auch in der Klimapolitik. Und an der Stelle bewegen sie sich dann eben doch. Inwieweit haben sie sich denn bewegt?
Eigentlich praktisch überhaupt nicht. Die USA sind tatsächlich der Meinung, sie haben das Internet erschaffen. Sie haben eigentlich die ganzen Hauptinvestitionen im Internet getätigt. Ihnen gehört eigentlich das Internet und deswegen wollen sie letztendlich die Kontrolle drüber behalten bzw. darf keine andere die Kontrolle drüber haben, aus Gründen der nationalen Sicherheit. Die Europäer haben drei Monate vor dem Gipfel auf der letzten Vorbereitungskonferenz versucht, eine Kompromissvorschlag in die Diskussion zu werfen, weil die Diskussion eigentlich ziemlich verfahren war mit den ganzen kritischen Ländern, die eigentlich so eine Weltregierung wollten, wo alle irgendwie Diplomaten hinschicken können und den USA, die eigentlich alles alleine weiter haben wollten. Und das fanden die USA alles andere als amüsant und haben eine globale Diplomatie und Medienkampagne gestartet mit Vorurteilen, wie die UN will das Internet übernehmen und so weiter und haben eigentlich alle auf Linie gebracht und haben bis zum Schluss sich standhaft gezeigt und eigentlich keinen Schritt bewegt. Und was wenigstens ein bisschen positiv war in der Debatte, die Europäische Union hat halt als Kompromissvorschlag unter anderem einen Global Forum on Internet Governance vorgeschlagen, was ursprünglich mal die Idee der internationalen Zivilgesellschaft war. Wir richten einen Multi-Stakeholder-Prozess ein, um diese Frage weiter zu diskutieren, um Fragen des Internet Governance in so einem Forum zu diskutieren und auch zu lösen. Und jetzt soll es dieses Global Forum on Internet Governance nächstes Jahr zum ersten Mal geben. Es ist noch relativ unklar, in welche Richtung sich das entwickelt, weil in diesen Gipfelpapieren mehr soll als muss Bestimmungen drinstehen. Aber es ist erstmal eine Chance, die Debatte weiterzuführen und zwar in einem offenen Prozess.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein weites Feld mit der WSIS. Auf netzpolitik.org hat Markus, hast du eine sehr umfangreiche Live-Berichterstattung gemacht. Wie lange warst du eigentlich da? Das war eine Woche fast, oder?
Ja, ich war acht Tage da. Der Gipfel selbst ging drei Tage, dann gab es noch drei Tage Vorbereitungskonferenz vorher und einen Tag haben wir dann noch Urlaub gemacht.
Das war dann die Session mit Gilberto Gil und Richard Storman?
Nein, das war Donnerstags nach dem zweiten Gipfeltag abends.
Und dann haben die sich ein bisschen hingesetzt und die Klampe gespielt?
Ja, Gilberto Gil hat Richard Storman einen Preis überreicht in so einem kleinen Haus in Tunesien, wo ein Free-Culture-Workshop unter anderem finanziert vom Brasilianischen Kulturministerium stattfand. Und Richard Storman ist halt dieser Preis für sein Lebenswerk verliehen worden und da waren so 30, 40 Leute und auf einmal fingen die halt an zu singen. Also Richard Storman fängt an zu singen und Gilberto Gil war dazu die Gitarre am Spielen. Ja, da war ich gerade auf Toilette, ich glaube, das hat er tatsächlich gemacht, aber ansonsten hat er noch ältere Songs aus den 80ern, so politische Parodien auf Ronald Reagan und so weiter gesungen.
Okay, da gibt es auch Videos, auch auf netzpolitik.org verlinkt. Zuletzt vielleicht noch mal dazu, es gab neben dem eigentlichen Konferenzgeschehen auch eine ganze Menge Repression. Tunesien ist ja eigentlich ein Treppenwitz, dass diese Konferenz ausgerechnet in Tunesien stattfand. Tunesien hat, glaube ich, nicht zu unrecht den Ruf, die stärkste Netzzensur zu haben. Nach China. Wie hat sich das konkret vor Ort so gezeigt?
Ja, also erstmal zu Tunesien. Das ist nicht nur das schöne Urlaubsland, oder das schöne billige Urlaubsland, was viele im Kopf haben. Tunesien ist eigentlich eine Diktatur mittlerweile. Seit 20 Jahren gibt es da einen Präsidenten an der Macht, sogenannten Präsidenten. Der hat sich auch gleich mal auf Lebenszeit ernannt und vor zwei Jahren von 99,8 Prozent der Bevölkerung nochmal bestätigen lassen, dass das okay war. Und damals, 1987, als er in die Macht kam, hat er eigentlich die ganze Opposition zerschlagen, ins Ausland oder in die Gefängnisse gesteckt. So und eigentlich alles assimiliert, was irgendwie da war an freien Gewerkschaften und so weiter. Und mittlerweile gibt es halt keine freie Presse mehr. Es gibt eigentlich kaum noch Opposition im Land. Die sitzen fast alle in Frankreich so, die es überlebt haben und auch nicht im Knast sitzen. Und ich weiß eigentlich auch nicht mehr so genau, wieso Tunesien irgendwie an die Macht kam oder diesen WSIS-Gipfel bekam. Ich glaube, das lag daran, ein afrikanisches Land dürfte den organisieren. Ich glaube, Tunesien hat einfach als erstes die Hand gehoben, wie das so auf internationaler Ebene ist und gesagt, wir machen es. Und dann hat man es halt so. Ja, und Tunesien war halt massiv die ganze Zeit schon in der Kritik, vor allen Dingen von Seiten der Zivilgesellschaft, dass halt so ein Land nicht Ausrichter dieses Gipfels sein kann, der eigentlich auch ein Gipfel der Informationsfreiheit werden sollte. Also, dass ein Land der Ausrichter ist, wo Menschenrechte mit Füßen getreten werden.
Und diese Freiheit hat aber auch vor Ort konkret gefehlt. Also Webseiten von Oppositionsgruppen, die sowieso gesperrt sind, waren auch, ich glaube, noch mal besonders unter Beschuss. Die Hotel-Internetzzugänge waren, glaube ich, auch überwacht. Ich habe verschiedene Berichte gesehen, wo auch Journalisten permanent verfolgt wurden von Wagen und meinten auch, das wäre völlig normal, dass man eigentlich die ganze Zeit jemanden anhand...
Ja, also erst mal, es war ein riesiger Sicherheitsapparat aufgebaut. Ich habe noch nie so viele Polizei- und Zivilgeheimdienstler gesehen, Unmengen, Straßen sperren überall. Natürlich, die hatten auch ein bisschen Angst vor Terroranschlägen. Aber wir versuchten halt, Veranstaltungen neben dem Gipfel, zum Beispiel ein Alternativgipfel, den Citizen Summit, zu organisieren, wo uns vernachlässigte Themen in diesem Gipfelprozess wie Datenschutz, Privacy, Menschenrechte in der Informationsgesellschaft oder Zugang zu Wissen thematisiert werden sollten. Und wir fanden überhaupt keinen Raum in Tunis. Also das führte halt dazu, dass selbst internationale Hotelketten immer aus fadenscheinigen Begründungen kurz vorher absagten, mal waren Sicherheitsgründen, mal aus Baugründen. Und dann sollte halt am Montag vor dem Gipfel, dem Goethe-Institut, noch mal ein letztes Vorbereitungstreffen stattfinden, wo auch der deutsche Botschafter mit hin wollte. Und als wir da ankamen, war halt das Gelände weiträumig abgesperrt von geheimen Polizei und wir wurden am Betreten unseres Goethe-Institutes gehindert. Selbst der deutsche Botschafter durfte mit zwei tunesischen Oppositionellen nicht rein. Die tunesischen Oppositionellen, die dabei waren, sollten in Autos gezerrt werden und wir wurden immer weiter verfolgt. Und später gab es dann noch eine Veranstaltung zusammen, die die Hannig-Bölt-Stiftung organisiert hatte. Das sollte halt so ein Treffen deutscher Zivilgesellschaft mit arabischer Zivilgesellschaft sein. Auch da dieselben Probleme, kein Veranstaltungsraum wurde gefunden. Dann hat eine unabhängige tunesische Frauenrechtsorganisation angeboten, in ihrem Hotel, in ihrem Büro zu tagen. Da fiel dann zwei Wochen vorher das Telefon, das Internet aus. Rein zufällig, technische Gründe wahrscheinlich, wurde nicht geklärt. Und als wir dann da um 17 Uhr auftauchten, war auch das Gelände weiträumig umsperrt. Uns wurde erklärt, die Veranstaltung ist illegal. Und ja, das war halt...
Tunisische Verhältnisse sozusagen.
Genau.
Ja, Chaosradio Express, wir berichten von WSIS, den World Summit on Information in Tunis, in Tunisien, der vor ein paar Wochen stattfand. Und Markus berichtet hier gerade von seinen Erfahrungen vor Ort. Vielleicht als letztes noch mal so zu dem Aspekt Netzzensur. Was wurde dort, also wie hat sich das konkret gezeigt, was jetzt im Netz selber gesperrt war? Hast du das wahrnehmen können?
Also wir haben eine Woche lang eigentlich alles untersucht, was wir so finden konnten. Die komplette tunesische Opposition ist natürlich komplett gesperrt. Unser Citizen Summit, unser Alternativgipfel war gesperrt. Französische Medien, viele Libra-Sans und so weiter sind komplett gesperrt. Reporter ohne Grenzen natürlich, währenddessen wiederum die deutsche Reporter ohne Grenzen-Seite funktionierte. Bei Google konnten wir Wohnsuchabfragen wie Anonymizer geblockt. Also es war eigentlich eine sehr intelligente Zensur, alles eingekauft von einer US-amerikanischen Firma natürlich. Weiß ich jetzt nicht genau den Namen, steht auch auf netzpolitik.org. Und ja, im Endeffekt für uns war es weniger das Problem, rauszukommen mit SSH-Tunneling in den Westen rein, aber in Tunesien soll man schon verschwinden, wenn man halt irgendwie verbotene Seiten unsurft und so weiter. Und das ist echt eine sophisticated Filterinfrastruktur, die die da aufgebaut haben.
Die jetzt, was man sich für Europa in irgendeiner Form wünschen würde, aber leider finden sich hier auch immer wieder Politiker, die ihm gerne auch entsprechen würden. Das sind ja leider. Ja, da haben wir ja im Prinzip auch schon so eine Überleitung zum anderen Thema, auf das wir hier noch zu sprechen kommen müssen. Stichwort hier, wieder so ein schönes politisches Buzzword, Data Retention oder auf Deutsch auch Vorrats, Datenspeicherung. Das ist etwas, was in diesem Jahr neu aufkam. Also nicht, dass es wirklich in diesem Jahr erfunden wurde, aber dass jetzt noch mal besondere Beschleunigungen in der Diskussion erfahren hat durch neue Maßnahmen auf EU-Ebene. Dort wird geplant, eine allgemeine Vorratsdatenspeicherung für Internetdatenverkehr einzuführen europaweit, sodass alle, ja das muss man sich mal vorstellen, alle Daten, die durchs Netz fließen, also alles, also nicht nur übertragen wird, sondern auch nochmal gespeichert wird.
Ja, also es geht eigentlich um die Verbindungsdaten. Also wer spricht mit wem, auf welche Webseiten surft man, wem schickt man eine SMS, mit wem jabbert man und so weiter. Also es geht weniger um die Inhalte jetzt im ersten Schritt, sondern einfach nur irgendwie die Logfiles speichern lassen. Und im Moment sieht es danach aus, dass halt mindestens ein Jahr sämtliche Telekommunikationsdaten, also Handydaten, ISCN-Daten und so weiter gespeichert werden und Internet mindestens ein halbes Jahr, wobei das halt offen formuliert ist. Bis zu zwei Jahre können das Regierungen machen. Für Polen gibt es noch einen extra Absatz. Die wollen das gleich 15 Jahre lang alles speichern. Und ja, das hat natürlich massivste Einflüsse oder auf verschiedenste Sachen. Also wie verhält man sich im Netz so? Datenschutz. Die wirtschaftliche Frage ist halt eine andere. Wer finanziert das Ganze? Und sehr komplexes Thema. Und steht am Mittwoch im Europaparlament zur Abstimmung.
Das heißt, also dort wird konkret darüber entschieden, ob die jetzt im ersten Schritt geplante Vorratsdatensprechung überhaupt eingeführt werden wird.
Ja, also wie auf europäischer Ebene immer, ist es ein bisschen komplexer. Da gibt es einerseits den EU-Rat, wo die ganzen Justizen, Innenminister drinne sitzen, die halt nach den Terroranschlägen in London und Madrid und so weiter tierische Panik schieben und halt am liebsten alles überwachen wollen. Und die sind natürlich in den letzten Monaten vorgeprescht mit Maximal-Forderungen und müssen natürlich noch irgendwie, weil es ja noch so was wie eine Demokratie in Europa gibt, das Europaparlament... Zumindest mal gefragt haben. Zumindest mal gefragt haben. Das Europaparlament hat so einen Bürgerrechtsausschuss, den Liebe-Ausschuss. Da hat man lange drüber debattiert und hat halt erklärt so, naja, was die EU-Minister wollen, das wollen wir nicht. Wir wollen was ganz anderes. Und hat halt eigentlich relativ kontriere Forderungen aufgestellt, die auch nicht aus Bürgerrechtssicht okay sind, aber ja, immer noch besser als das, was die EU-Minister wollen. Ja, und dann haben sich jetzt die EU-Minister mit der sogenannten großen Koalition im Europaparlament auf einen anderen Kompromiss geeinigt. Das heißt, mit den Sozialdemokraten und mit den Konservativen wurde das mal ein bisschen abgedealt, so leichte Entschärfungen so, aber im Endeffekt so weitestgehend die Maximal-Forderung. Was kann man da konkret gegen unternehmen? Also am Mittwoch ist die Abstimmung im Europaparlament, wo halt dieser Kompromiss der großen Koalition mit den EU-Ministern sozusagen zur Abstimmung steht. Alternativ gibt es auch noch Anträge, zum Beispiel der Grünen, die halt einen Antrag gestellt haben, die ganze Richtlinie zurückzuweisen. Und es gibt halt Änderungsanträge aus dem Liebe, also dem Bürgerrechtsausschuss, die Richtlinie zu entkräften. Und das Hauptproblem ist, wie immer im Europäischen Parlament, es gibt ganz viele Parlamentarier, die alle ihre Spezialthemen haben und es gibt immer nur ganz wenige Experten, die in einem Thema drin sind und ihren Fraktionen, die eigentlich auch sehr vielfältig sind. Also das sind deutsche Konservative in der konservativen Fraktion zusammen mit irgendwelchen italienischen Konservativen und polnischen. Und die sind alle leicht anders, so bilden da mal so eine Interessengruppe, weil alle irgendwie konservativ sind zum Beispiel. Die muss man halt überzeugen.
Auf welche Art und Weise kann das erfolgen?
Also das Ganze wird wahrscheinlich Dienstag veröffentlicht. Es ist eigentlich noch einen Tag Zeit, bei seinem persönlichen Europaparlamentarier anzurufen, die darüber aufzuklären, dass sie eigentlich jetzt...
Mein persönlicher Europaparlamentarier?
Mein persönlicher Europaparlamentarier. In Berlin gibt es glaube ich fünf Europaparlamentarier, aber als besorgte Bürger dort anzurufen und mal ein bisschen Wind zu machen, dass es nicht geht, dass das Europaparlament jetzt so eine Richtlinie verabschiedet, die halt den Datenschutz auf den Kopf stellt, die die komplette Bevölkerung in Europa, 450 Millionen Bürger, unter Generalverdacht stellt und eigentlich der letzte... Also selbst der Industrieverband Bitkom spricht schon von dem Schritt in den Überwachungsstaat und wenn Bitkom das schon sagt, dann können wir uns dem auch anschließen. Das ist eigentlich nicht akzeptabel, was da beschlossen wird und ich vermute mal...
Wobei ich glaube, deren Interesse doch weitgehend eher in den damit verbundenen Kosten...
Ja, also die Industrie soll für die ganzen Überwachungsmaßnahmen bezahlen. Das machen nicht die Verursacher, also die Regierung, sondern die Industrie soll das bezahlen. Wenn die Industrie das bezahlt, dann kommen letztendlich wir Verbraucher dafür auf. Also wir werden auch noch zukünftig halt höhere Telekommunikationspreise haben für mehr Überwachung. Und das ist nicht akzeptabel und da sollte man Bewusstsein schaffen bei den Europaparlamentariern, weil ich glaube nicht, dass ein Großteil der Europaparlamentarier überhaupt weiß, was sie am Mittwoch unter dem Namen Data Retention irgendwie abstimmen werden.
Das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen. Das hat man häufiger schon gehabt, auch wenn man so mit Bundestagsabgeordneten mal gesprochen hat, als sie über die EU-Verfassung abgestimmt haben und wenn man so ein bisschen...
Da hat keiner die gelesen.
Da hat keiner gelesen und keiner wusste so ganz genau. Ich glaube, irgendein Presse-Team ist mal rumgelaufen, hat mal so die zehn wichtigsten Fragen, die dort beantwortet werden, gestellt und die Leute sagen einfach, ja, es müsste ja eigentlich so und so sein, ging meistens komplett in die falsche Richtung. Und auf der anderen Seite, der große Aktionismus rund um die Verhinderung von Software-Patenten auf EU hat, glaube ich, auch gezeigt, dass es eben auch möglich ist, über das EU-Parlament Druck zu machen. Das ist also gar nicht so, dass die das einfach nicht wahrnehmen wollen, sondern ich glaube auch, dass es einfach so ist, dass das Parlament als solches gar nicht wahrgenommen wird von den Leuten in Europa, einfach die mir noch so richtig auf die Idee gekommen ist, den mal die Hölle heiß zu machen.
Ja, so ein wichtiges Argument jetzt hier noch, wenn man halt seine persönlichen Europaparlamentarier anruft, also anrufen und Faxe schicken ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoller als E-Mails. Bei E-Mails kann man schnell den Junkfilter schicken. Ist zu sagen, das Ganze wird, soll in der ersten Lesung eigentlich schon beschlossen werden. Also normalerweise hat man im Europaparlament oder in jedem Parlament mehrere Lesungen. Das bedeutet, zwischen jeder Lesung ist noch ein bisschen Zeit, das weiter zu diskutieren. Und weil es jetzt so ein Kompromiss der Großen Koalition gibt, die die Mehrheit hat sozusagen und theoretisch halt dafür stimmen kann, soll das jetzt einfach mal ganz schnell ohne Debatte irgendwie durchkommen.
Genau, statt Januar.
Und bei solchen wichtigen Entscheidungen, die massiv in die Grundrechte der europäischen Bürger eingreifen, ist es wohl das Mindeste, dass sie noch ein zweites Mal darüber debattieren und sich noch ein bisschen Zeit lassen. Also die Parlamentarier zumindest darauf hinweisen, dass eine zweite Lesung sehr wichtig und sinnvoll ist und im Interesse aller Bürger Europa.
Hintergrundinformationen zu dem Thema findet sich unter anderem unter dataretentionisnosolution.com. Das ist eine Informationswebseite, die bis November auch eine Petition vorgehalten hat. Die ist jetzt bereits geschlossen, wurde von 58.000 Leuten unterschrieben. Aber es gibt dort auch ein Wiki, wo man sich weiter informieren kann. Das solltet ihr euch auf jeden Fall anschauen. Den Link packen wir natürlich hier auch noch mal mit rein in die Lyrics. Ja, und ich denke, wir werden das Thema noch häufiger haben. Also nicht nur die data retention, sondern insbesondere dieser politische Druck, der über EU-Ebene ausgeübt wird, gerade auch um so Probleme, die unter Umständen nationaler Regierungen haben, etwas durchzusetzen, zu umgehen, wie wir das beim elektronischen Reisepass auch schon gesehen haben und bei zahlreichen anderen Maßnahmen.
Also bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung kann man halt noch erwähnen. Der Deutsche Bundestag hat letztes Jahr in einem interfraktionellen Antrag komplett geschlossen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung abgelehnt. Das hat halt unsere Minister Zypress und Schillie nicht davon abgehalten, auf europäischer Ebene das weiter voranzutreiben. Und jetzt kommt es halt über die europäische Ebene zurück. Und wenn diese Richtlinie am Mittwoch abgestimmt wird, dann wird sie nächstes übernächstes Jahr im Deutschen Bundestag sein. Und die ganzen Fraktionen, die sie damals abgelehnt haben, müssen sie jetzt implementieren in nationales Recht.
Genau, was haben wir mit unserem nationalen Parlament zu tun? Tschüss . Ach ja, Europa. Man will eigentlich nur noch seufzen. Letztes Kapitel in dem großen Seufzer, in dem großen Stoßseufzer ist Frankreich. Ich weiß eigentlich immer noch nicht so richtig, was da eigentlich gerade losgeht. Also vor ein paar Tagen brach so die Nachricht durch, dass in Frankreich auf nationaler Ebene ein Gesetz vorangepeitscht werden soll, was, wie würdest du es formulieren, die Protokolle versucht zu unterbinden, die in der Lage sind, Dateinhalte, Medieninhalte, die ohne Digital Rights Management oder Watermarking oder ähnlichen Sachen versehen sind, zu unterbinden.
Ja, also ich habe es die digitale Katastrophe genannt.
Klingt noch sehr treffend.
Ja, und zwar geht es darum, 2001 hat es auf europäischer Ebene die sogenannte European Copyright Directive gegeben. Das ist halt die Urheberrechtsrichtlinie, vergleichbar mit dem US-amerikanischen DMCA, Digital Millennium Copyright Act, und in Deutschland wurde das Ganze im sogenannten ersten Korb des Urheberrechts umgesetzt und mittlerweile gibt es ja jetzt den zweiten Korb seit schon einem Jahr und der wird auch nächstes Jahr uns noch mit beschäftigen, halt sozusagen die Korrekturen vorzunehmen.
Dauere Beweise, Stress.
Frankreich selbst hat sich halt drei, vier Jahre Zeit gelassen mit der Umsetzung dieser Richtlinie und Frankreich ist gleichzeitig dadurch aufgefallen durch eine sehr liberale Rechtsgebung oder Justiz. So im letzten Jahr zum Beispiel wurde einem Verbraucher Recht zugesprochen, der halt seine Mulholland Drive DVD nicht einfach so kopieren konnte. Der hat halt mithilfe der französischen Verbraucherschutzzentrale geklagt und Recht bekommen. Ein anderer Fall war, das ist ein 22-jähriger Falschherer, der so einen Haufen Filme, was ich zu Hause hatte, wieder vom Gericht irgendwie mit Bezug auf das Recht auf Privatgruppie nach Hause geschickt wurde. Und da sind natürlich die Lobbyisten massiv aufs Parlament zu gerannt, auf die Regierung.
Und haben gesagt, so geht das ja nun nicht.
So geht das nicht. Und jetzt soll im Schnelldurchlauf bis Weihnachten eine Gesetzgebung durchgebracht werden, die halt massiv von der Business Software Alliance, von Vivendi Universal, also so eine Mischung aus Bertelsmann und Telekom zusammen, größten Medienkonzernen in Frankreich, und von Sargem, der...
Sargem, die mit den hässlichen Telefonen.
Französischen, nee, mit C. So was wie die französische GEMA halt massiv gelobbiert wurde. Und da gibt es halt einige Punkte, die halt eigentlich schon die Haare zu Berge steigen lassen. Man möchte halt verpflichtend durchsetzen, dass halt Software und Medienabspiegeräte, DRM und Wasserzeichen implementiert haben müssen. Da gibt es so kleine Probleme mit freier Software, weil unter anderem GPL sieht nicht vor, dass DRM damit implementiert werden kann. Also es könnte halt zu einem Verbot von freien Mediaplayern führen. Das könnte auch...
So wie sich dieser Vorstoß zuerst einmal gelesen hat, wenn das so jetzt die Beschlusslage wäre, müsste man ja im Prinzip sofort HTTP, also eigentlich müsste das Internet sofort abgeschaltet werden.
Ja, also im Endeffekt muss man sich das so vorstellen, das ist halt natürlich ein feuchter Traum der Rechteinhaber, so dass sie halt eigentlich ihre Maximalforderungen durchgesetzt bekamen. Mir ist jetzt der genaue Gesetzestext nicht bekannt, weil ich bin das Französische nicht so mächtig, um das jetzt lesen zu können. Das ist natürlich immer die Frage, wie kriegt man das letztendlich genau definiert in juristischer Rechtssprache und was ist darin eingeschlossen und was nicht so? Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass die da Kollateralschäden irgendwie mit in die Gesetzgebung einfließen lassen, um halt weitestgehend so das abzudecken, was sie wollen, nämlich ja, Media Player aller Art irgendwie zu DRM zu verpflichten.
Ja, was natürlich auch insofern ganz interessant ist, dass Frankreich ja auch eine extrem starke Open-Source-Szene hat, insbesondere genau in diesem Bereich, also das VLC-Projekt, das im Wesentlichen von französischen Programmierern vorangetrieben worden, also VLC, dieser freie Media Player, wo jetzt auch der x264, der neue mpeg-4-kompatible Videocodec mitentwickelt wurde. Und schon durch die Maßnahmen der Softwarepatentengesetzgebung haben die sich extrem in ihrer Existenz bedroht gefühlt. Das geht natürlich jetzt alles noch einen Schritt weiter. Also wie man es auch dreht und wendet, an diesem Montag können wir irgendwie kaum schöne Nachrichten bringen.
Ja, es geht noch weiter. Also diese DRM-Pflicht ist ja noch nicht alles. Die wollen tatsächlich auch auf Ebene der Access-Provider durchsetzen, dass es ein Filtering stattfindet, dass man halt nicht mehr einfach so MP3s, sagen wir mal, per Mail verschieben kann. Genau. Und zwar ja, auf Ebene der Internet Provider soll eine Filterinfrastruktur, eine Zensurinfrastruktur für halt MP3s, die halt nicht trust-worthy sind, die halt nicht irgendwie DRM-geschützt sind und so weiter aufgebaut werden, weil ja, sonst kann man ja immer noch weiter irgendwie MP3s zumailen, Patchupper schicken, File-Sharing benutzen und das ist halt ein massiver Eingriff in Grundrechte, weil da geht es um Zensur und das halt auch nur, ja, um Rechteinhaber sozusagen zu schützen, auf Kosten der Allgemeinheit.
Es ist wirklich zum Heulen, Leute. Also es ist einfach, ihr da draußen merkt es doch einfach bitte mal, es ist einfach nicht verhinderbar und man kann...
Doch, es ist verhinderbar.
Also das Kopieren nicht. Das Kopieren ist nicht verhinderbar. Die Gesetze sind vielleicht noch verhinderbar, das hoffe ich auch schwer, dass die verhinderbar sind, denn selbst wenn sie kommen, erzeugen sie einfach zunächst einmal Stress, aber ändern letztlich gar nichts. Wohin wir müssen, hinkommen müssen, ist eine neue Kultur zu entwickeln, mit dem freien Weiterleiten von Daten umzugehen. Da gibt es viele gute Ansätze, Creative Commons, da sehe ich schon, wie sich das hier wohltuend schon auf diesen Podcast auswirkt. Also selbe Produktion wäre so vor drei Jahren einfach schlicht nicht möglich gewesen, ohne nicht zumindest großen Stress zu riskieren. Und an der Stelle entstehen auch neue Sachen, entstehen auch neue Märkte, das man so in Richtung der Wirtschaft auch mal gesagt, vielleicht hört ihr ja auch mal zu, das wäre ja mal was neues. Und man kann eigentlich nur noch mit dem Kopf schütteln bei vielen Sachen. Auf der einen Seite, weil sie so sinnlos sind, auf der anderen Seite, weil sie so viel Stress erzeugen und auf der anderen Seite, weil man auch eine ganz widerliche Wursthaftigkeit dort hinter ausmachen kann, die von den Firmen kommen, die einfach an nichts anderem interessiert sind, als an ihren persönlichen Vorteilen. Und letzten Endes, glaube ich, bauen sie sich einfach selber Mauern, hauen sie sich ihre eigenen Brückenpfeiler weg, weil sie die ganze Kreativität, insbesondere in der Softwarelandschaft, zu niedermachen und irgendwann werden wir einfach von den Ländern überholt werden, die klug genug sind, diesen ganzen Scheiß nicht mitzumachen oder sich zumindest nicht sofort dazu zwingen lassen, alles mitspielen.
Ja, es ist eigentlich ein Kulturkampf, der da stattfindet zwischen Old Media, New Media, zwischen neuen kreativen, innovativen Produktionsformen im Internet, wie freier Software, Wikipedia, Creative Commons und den Alteingesessenen, die Angst haben, ihre Freunde und ihre Oligopole zu verlieren.
Ich habe schon, als diese Softwarepatente angenommen wurden, also als es drohte, dass sie angenommen werden, gab es ja die Entscheidung der, ich hoffe, ich kriege das richtig zusammen, aber ich glaube, in Indien haben sie sich dann kurz bevor das bei uns ein Thema war, haben die so auch nochmal drüber nachgedacht, ob sie jetzt auch mal Softwarepatente einführen sollen, und haben nachgedacht und dann so so, ah, nö, also eigentlich nö.
Das war aber nicht so einfach.
Das war nicht so einfach. Ja, ich weiß nicht, was letzten Endes sie dazu bewogen hat, aber bestimmt auch die Aussicht schlicht und ergreifend davon zu profitieren, dass die anderen sich so was zulegen und Indien natürlich auch als einer der wichtigsten Softwarestandorte mittlerweile auf diesem Planeten da einfach...
Du hast als Schwellenland eigentlich gar kein Interesse daran, irgendwie die Patentierung, ja, oder die Patente von westlichen Firmen sozusagen in deinem Land zuzulassen, weil...
Und wir sind auch ein Schwellenland, wenn es ums Internet geht.
Vor allen Dingen Deutschland hat auch relativ wenig Softwarepatente. Die meisten sind im Besitz von US und japanischen Firmen. Und die sind dann die größten Profiteure.
Okay, ich denke, jetzt haben wir drei große Themen... Drei große Themen hier weitläufig diskutiert. Auf netzpolitik.org bloggt Markus Schleißig vieles dazu. Ihr findet auch auf www.ccc.de Hintergründe und natürlich auch an vielen anderen Stellen im Netz, die jetzt ohne weiteres nicht aufzuzählen sind. Zumindest nicht hier. Feedback in der Datei, im Feed. Feedback auch von euch ist nach wie vor erwünscht. Entweder per Mail oder über unsere Chaosradio Telefonnummer. Vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen Vorab-Feedback zu künftigen Themen. Da kommt schon das eine oder andere ran, was für Themen ihr euch so wünscht. Ich habe jetzt noch keine konkrete Liste gemacht, was als nächstes so kommen soll. Demnächst werde ich auf jeden Fall noch mal ein wenig darüber berichten, wie das hier ganz konkret mit dem Podcasting abgeht. Also mal ein kleiner technischer Blick auf Produktionsmethoden jenseits der großen Politik. Und natürlich, wie sollte es auch anders sein, in den nächsten Tagen verstärkte Sendefrequenz von unserer Seite, weil der 22. Chaos Communication Kongress vor der Tür steht, vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember in Berlin am Alexanderplatz, im Berliner Kongresscenter. Ihr seid alle eingeladen, dort hinzukommen. Viele interessante Vorträge zu vielen wichtigen Themen. Wir möchten, dass ihr dabei seid. Und nein, es ist nicht nur eine Veranstaltung für Hacker, es ist eine Veranstaltung für alle Leute, die das Denken noch nicht aufgegeben haben. Und wir möchten auch gerne mit euch zusammenkommen, um euch mitzuteilen, was unsere Erkenntnisse sind und um auch hören zu können, was eure Erkenntnisse sind. Ja, in diesem Sinne, ich bedanke mich bei dir, Markus. Und bei euch fürs Zuhören. Wieder mal ein längerer Podcast, aber wir haben es unter einer Stunde geschafft. Und ja, ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag. Bis bald.